surely suffering Injustice is terrible
but what is far worse is the corrosion
of soul that takes place when one
commits an injustice in other words
being unjust is far more damaging to the
moral structure of one's personality
than enduring the slings and arrows
visited upon one by the Injustice of
someone else so there's the question
young brothers and sisters my fellow
graduates today what kind of soul will
you have what kind of person will you be
will you do whatever it takes to get
what you want or will you accept even
great suffering in order to do what is
right everything else in your life will
flow from how you answer that question